[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 146 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
My name is Mark Mandel,
and I'm here, as always,
with my colleague,
Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
Doing great.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing all right.
I'm doing very well.
Very excited for
today's episode.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
this week in particular,
we're very excited to
have with us Jeff Dean.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Who you may
have heard about him if you
know a little bit
about Google and AI
in TensorFlow and TPUs and
big data systems and cats.
[CAT PURRING]
You may have heard about him.
MARK MANDEL: Cats.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, cats.
Anyway, all the things.
MARK MANDEL: It's a thing.
OK, cool.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All the things that
come to computer systems,
hardware, and all that.
So we had a great
conversation with him
and covered a lot
of these topics.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
part of the reason
why we have this
interview this week
is because this week
is Deep Learning
Indaba, which is happening
out in Stellenbosch in South
Africa.
And it's bringing
together researchers
from different countries
within the African continent
to share their knowledge.
Jeff Dean is going
to be speaking there,
and I'm also going to be
there recording some episodes.
So, you know, we wanted to
emphasize that a little bit.
We don't actually get
into the podcast about it
until later in,
but you can listen
and hear about what
he's going to talk about
at the conference.
As always, before
we get into that,
we are going to start out with
our cool things of the week.
And we will end with the
question of the week.
And we have a
special guest joining
us to help with the
question of the week,
how do I get data from
IoT core to display
in real time on a web front end?
MARK MANDEL: Yes, and we have
Gabe Weiss joining us today.
GABE WEISS: Hi, friends.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So, to start out
the cool things of the week,
something that I caught
was that Google has recently
put into beta Data Set Search.
And so I caught this,
actually, because Ben Hamner,
who is the CTO at Kaggle,
had tweeted this out today.
And specifically, he was
noting how, you know,
this helps to index
metadata on open data sets
and should be pretty
useful for people
who are researchers
and those that
are curious about
public data sets
and wanting to explore them.
So we'll include the link
to it, but it's pretty much
a search tool.
It's a Google search tool, it's
just specifically on data sets.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I wanted to talk about this
really cool thing I liked, too,
which is we're expanding
our public data
sets for geospatial
and ML-based Analytics.
So you may have heard
back at Cloud Next,
we announced an additional five
petabytes of BigQuery storage
available for public data sets.
In the blog post we'll
link to in the show notes,
we also talk about that this
additional storage will also
be available for the
next five years, which
is also really cool.
Since Next, though, we have
onboarded seven new data sets
that define boundaries
in the United States
by parameters such as zip
code and things like that,
basically to support
geospatial queries.
So we have a whole bunch of
new data in there for you
to do geospatial stuff,
to do ML based Analytics
to use the new ML toolkits that
are available now in BigQuery.
And if you want to take
advantage of any of those,
make sure you head over to
the Google Cloud Platform
Marketplace.
There's a Data Set
Filter you can go into.
And at last look,
it looks like we
have about 101 different
public data sets for you
to play with on BigQuery.
And you can do up to
a terabyte of querying
on BigQuery for
free, which is also
pretty amazing-- per month.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another
thing we wanted to mention,
again referencing Kaggle
and also Google AI,
is that there is a new
challenge through Kaggle
that Google AI has
posted, specifically
to encourage the
users and the Kagglers
out there to develop
models that are
more robust to blind spots
that exist in data sets.
We've talked about
this in past, seen
many people discuss machine
learning bias and fairness.
In particular, that,
you know, really stems
from the data itself and
how the data can really
be biased in what
you've gathered
and how that can then influence
the model that's built.
So their challenge
is specifically
to help identify techniques and
approaches to account for that
and to make the bottle
more robustness.
This challenge in particular
is set to run in two stages.
They've got the
information on the website
that we'll keep a link in to.
But it's going to wrap up
around the time of NIPS.
That's later this
year, December.
And so you can check
that out and experiment.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
I also want to mention that we
were checking out the top 100
podcasts in tech recently
on iTunes, and we're in it.
[TRUMPET PLAYING]
Which is kind of cool.
So thank you very much to
everyone who's been listening,
people who have
rated us on iTunes,
and basically have
supported the podcast.
That's a really
nice little thing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And last but not
least, if you want
to know what makes TPUs fine
tuned for deep learning,
we've got a blog post
that we're going to share
that you can look into this.
And, you know, we figured
this is especially
relevant for today's episode.
But it helps step you
through what neural nets are.
It help step you
through how TPUs work
as well as in
comparison to CPUs.
And you see these
nice graphics that
do a good job in terms of
stepping you through what
that looks like visually.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
some pricing information
at the bottom, too.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark.
I think we should go
ahead and get into it.
We've got a great
interview now with Jeff.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go
talk to your buddy Jeff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, my buddy.
We play cards.
We're thrilled today to
have with us Jeff Dean, who
is heading up Google AI.
Thank you, Jeff, for joining us.
JEFF DEAN: Thanks very
much for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: So Jeff, I
mean, I know a lot of people
know who you are.
But we always ask
all of the people
who come on the show to tell
a little bit about themselves,
what your background
is, what do you do.
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
So at the moment, I am
leading Google's AI division.
Internally, we know that as
Google Research and Machine
Intelligence, but externally,
we can use Google AI sometimes,
depending on who
we're talking to.
And so that organization
does lots of different kinds
of computer science research.
We do fundamental
research, trying
to create new logarithms and new
techniques to solve problems.
We do a fair amount of work
with Google product areas
to work with interesting
research problems
in the context of products
and get sort of our research
out into the Google products
that everyone knows and loves
and uses.
We also have been doing a bit
more work on sort of systems
infrastructure for
enabling our research,
but then also creating tools
that enable internal developers
at Google but also
external developers
when we open source things.
So TensorFlow, for example,
came out of our group
and is a popular machine
learning toolkit.
We feel like that's a
good way to really broaden
the impact of the
research that we're doing,
is to make it easy for people
to then build on the work
that we're doing and have
good tools available.
And then the fourth
kind of thing
that we generally do is try
to find new areas that Google
doesn't currently work in where
we think our research can make
a big impact.
So we've been doing a lot
of work on sort of machine
learning for health care,
machine learning for robotics,
because we think those are
kind of new emerging areas
where machine learning
and our research
will make a big difference.
MELANIE WARRICK: In terms of the
work that your team is doing,
what does it mean for you?
And what does it
look like for you
now that-- because I know
this is a fairly new position,
to a degree, that you're in
as the leader of Google AI
this year, right?
JEFF DEAN: Yes, yes.
I took on this role in, I
guess, late March, early April.
And basically my goal is to
inspire our great researchers
to do great research
and to tackle
the important ambitious
problems that I
think we should be working on.
I spend Mondays coding.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
JEFF DEAN: With my
colleague Sanjay
Ghemawat, who I've been
working with for many years.
I kind of probably have
four or five other projects
that I'm involved in, in
an actual technical level,
where I go to the
weekly meetings
and make sort of technical
suggestions and so on.
And then the rest
of my time is spent
kind of trying to steer a
reasonably large organization
to do the right things
and to make sure
that we're focused on the
right problems and have impact.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
curious, what do you code in?
JEFF DEAN: Mostly C++.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fun.
So, I like asking
these questions
for the people who
work in AI and ML,
because we get varying answers.
What does AI mean to you?
JEFF DEAN: It means
basically being
able to have computer systems
that can solve problems
that you would think of as
requiring human intelligence.
MARK MANDEL: I think
that's actually
the most concise
answer we've ever got.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
pretty straightforward.
Well, in terms of the work
that you do, what do you
think are some of the biggest
challenges that you are up
against?
JEFF DEAN: Really,
it's an exciting time
to be in the field of
computer science research
and machine learning
research, because there
is an explosion of
interest in this field, as
in the last maybe
seven or eight years,
collectively, as a
research community,
we've really pushed forward
what computers can do.
I think this is sort of most
striking in the computer vision
field where essentially
using deep learning
models for computer vision has
suddenly transformed computers
from not being able to
see very well to now
actually being able to see.
And if you think about
the impact on the world
that that will
have, and is already
having, that's transformative.
Suddenly you can have
automated machines
able to perceive the
world around them,
able to sort of understand
what they're looking at.
And that has huge implications
for general computer vision.
So, it's a key enabler for
a lot of the experience
that Google Photos
provides to Google users.
We can understand that's
a picture of a doberman,
and that's a mountain.
But it also means transformative
things in health care.
So tons and tons of medical
imaging-related problems
now are sort of tackle-able
with automated machine
learning algorithms
and assisting
sort of medical
professionals in that way.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
JEFF DEAN: Robotics,
it's very clear.
If you want to build a
robot, it's very helpful
if the robot can see.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
JEFF DEAN: So, that
has big implications.
And I think we're making
significant progress
in other fields related
to machine learning,
so things like natural language
understanding and speech
recognition.
You've seen tremendous advances
over the last six or seven
years.
And that really means there's
all these opportunities
about how we should be
using these new capabilities
to affect the world, to
make it a better place
to build new things that
we couldn't build before.
And I think that's
the excitement.
And the flood of interest
in studying this field, how
do people do research
in this field,
how can more people enter
this field and do research?
MELANIE WARRICK: So we
spoke earlier this year
with Dr. Fei-Fei
Li around Cloud AI.
We spoke not too long ago with
Raia Hadsell out of DeepMind,
and talked about some
of the robotics research
that they're doing.
How does Brain and
Google AI collaborate
with the different groups?
JEFF DEAN: Right.
So, we actually have
strong collaborations
across all of Google
and even across all
of Alphabet in many areas.
So with Cloud AI,
for example, many
of the sort of things that
they are bringing to market
started as research projects
in the Google AI Research
Division.
And we're now
collaborating closely
to bring things like
the AutoML research
that was started into
products like Cloud AutoML,
where now customers who have
Computer Vision or other kinds
of problems that
maybe don't have
sophisticated machine
learning developers on staff
but want to be able
to take advantage
of the machine learning
capabilities that now exist, we
have systems that can
automatically train and learn
to solve new problems that
a customer might have.
They might have pictures of
broken parts on their assembly
line and not broken
parts and they
want to be able to distinguish.
And they can essentially
just upload those images
and get a trained
model that helps them
with that particular
task, even without having,
sort of, a master's
level machine
learning expert on staff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Makes sense.
I know one of your areas
of passion in particular,
and where you've had
a significant impact,
especially, is around the Tensor
Processing Units, the TPUs.
What helped drive or inspire
the initial development
of the TPUs?
And I know you've had
this conversation before,
but, you know, especially
from your experience
as you were coming
along and getting
into technology
to begin with, how
did that come about for you?
JEFF DEAN: Right.
So I've always been interested
in how can computers
solve interesting problems.
And one interesting
way of doing that is
to bring more computation to
bear on problems that you can
then use more
sophisticated algorithms
or you can use larger data
sets to derive better insights.
And so having more
computation is generally
a good thing in computing.
And around the time
of maybe 2011, 2012,
when the Google Brain
Project that I co-founded
was just getting
started, we started
to collaborate with a number
of different product teams
at Google to use deep learning
in some of the products.
And the ones we collaborated
with most closely with
were the Speech
Recognition team to replace
kind of the older style
machine learning model
that they were using
for speech recognition
with a deep learning-based model
for the acoustic portion of it.
You know, the part
of the model that
goes from a very small audio
recording to part of a word.
Is it "buh" or a
"fff" or a "sss"?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
JEFF DEAN: And then
there was another model
that we didn't
focus on initially,
kind of after that
stage of the processing.
But replacing the acoustic
model with a deep learning-based
acoustic model gave a lot of
gains in recognition accuracy.
And so we could tell that as
speech recognition gets better,
people are going to
use it more and more.
And so I started to do
some back-of-the-envelope
calculations of like, well, what
happens if people start talking
to their phone three
minutes a day, right?
Because they're going to draft
all their emails with speech
or something.
And at the time, we had
just lots and lots of CPUs
in our data center.
And if you looked at
how much computation
that would be required if
100 million of our users
started to do that,
that was actually
kind of daunting and scary.
We would have to essentially
double the computing footprint
of Google just to support
like a slightly better speech
recognition model for a
modest fraction of our users.
MELANIE WARRICK: Seems legit.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah, so it
seems a little scary.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
JEFF DEAN: But it's clear
we want to deploy that
to our users, because the
gains in recognition accuracy
are actually quite significant.
And so we started
to look at well,
what could we do for these
kinds of deep learning models
that would be more
computationally efficient?
And there are two
really nice properties
that deep learning models have.
So first, they are very
tolerant of reduced precision.
So essentially, if
you do the precisions
to one decimal
digit of accuracy,
that's actually perfectly
fine for these models.
You don't need six or
seven digits of precision
like you would in floating
point computations or even
more in double combinations.
And the second
property they have
is that all the
algorithms are made up
of different compositions of
handful of building blocks,
essentially matrix
multiplies, vector dot
products linear
algebra-style operations.
So if you can build
hardware that is only
designed to accelerate low
precision, linear algebra,
you're golden.
And that enables you
to then really tailor
the hardware to do only that.
It doesn't need to do twisty
branch-y C++ code of all kinds
of arbitrary things,
pointer dereferences,
just low-precision
linear algebra,
then suddenly you can rethink
how you would completely design
a computer to do only that.
MARK MANDEL: Since it's
focused in exactly what it
is it can do, does that mean
there are certain applications
that are better
or worse for a TPU
that you might use
something else for,
or how does that work?
JEFF DEAN: Right.
So this is one of the
double-edged swords
of specialization is if
you over-specialize, then
it's not generally applicable.
But if you make something
very generally applicable,
then it doesn't get all the
performance benefits you
could get from specialization.
And we actually chose, I think,
a pretty good balance for TPUs.
They're essentially
designed to accelerate
exactly the kinds of operations
you find in deep learning
models.
So, they're not general-purpose
sort of computational devices.
But they are not tailored
to a particular model.
They are tailored
to all the kinds
of operations you generally
find deep learning models.
And so you can run
vision models on them.
You can run speech models.
You can run recurrent
language models.
The first TPU, TPU
v1, was targeted
at only inference,
where you actually
need even less precision
than the training process.
And that was our most
pressing problem.
That was how we could get the
speech recognition model out
to the world without doubling
Google's data center footprint.
And then the second
TPU was really
targeted at both
training and inference.
And the reason we didn't
bite that off first
was that training is a much
more complex hardware design
problem.
Because for
inference, usually you
can design things so
that a single model
will fit on one chip.
And if you need more capacity,
you just kind of stamp out
lots of copies of
that system and put
a lot of boards in
a lot of computers,
and all of a sudden you have
lots of speech recognition
capacity.
For training, it's very
unlikely for large models
you can get a single
chip to be fast enough
to train a model very fast.
And what you really
want in training
is fast turnaround for
machine learning experiments
or huge scalability so you can
train very large models on very
large data sets
very quickly and be
able to iterate from a machine
learning research perspective.
Or a deployed
system, you know, you
might want to retrain your
model every 10 minutes,
because your data changes.
There, it's not just
a chip design problem.
It's actually a whole
computer system.
It's more like a
supercomputer design problem
where you have
the chips and then
you have some
complicated interconnect
that connects them together.
You have cooling issues for how
do you cool this giant thing?
It's made up of multiple racks.
And so that's why we didn't bite
that off in the first system,
but chose to wait till the
second iteration of the TPU
design to tackle
training as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you
announced this year version 3
of TPUs as well.
JEFF DEAN: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: And am
I right in remembering
that the cooling
system, it's now liquid?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Fancy.
JEFF DEAN: So it turns out--
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
it is fancy.
Any time you mix computers and
water, it's always exciting.
[LAUGHTER]
So the TPU v3, which Sundar
announced at Google I/O
in May of 2018, essentially
got water cooling.
So a board has four
of these chips on it,
and the water
cooling kind of goes
to the surface of these chips
and takes excess heat away.
And the largest
footprint deployment--
we call these things pods--
the TPU v2 pods were
essentially made up
of 64 of those devices,
256 TPU v2 chips.
And the pods scale for
the TPU v3 is much larger.
So we have about eight
times as much computation
in the TPU v3 pod as we
did in the TPU v2 pod.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know a couple
of the people on your team
was specifically running a
Stanford DAWNBench on it,
and they were showing
the differences
in terms of its performance.
Right now all that's going in my
head right now as the ImageNet,
but--
JEFF DEAN: I call do that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--DAWNBench-- please.
JEFF DEAN: So, DAWNBench
is a new machine learning
benchmark set up by a
research group at Stanford,
the DAWN research
group, that is designed
to look at a variety of
different kinds of machine
learning problems, both training
and inference, and measures
a few different metrics.
So one of them is for a
particular machine learning
problem, how quickly can you get
to a certain level of accuracy
that is sort of a good level
of accuracy for that problem?
And one of them is a ImageNet
processing benchmark,
where you have to get
to 76% top-1 accuracy.
MELANIE WARRICK: And this
is classifying images.
JEFF DEAN: Classifying
images, right.
MELANIE WARRICK: ImageNet
is very much like that.
JEFF DEAN: Right, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
this is what you--
JEFF DEAN: You
get a color image.
You have to classify it into
one of 1,000 categories.
Its actually pretty
hard, human error rate
in the top-1
accuracy is about 5%.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
JEFF DEAN: Because its got
like 40 breeds of dogs,
and you should be
able to distinguish--
MARK MANDEL: And so I'm
guessing the TPUs did pretty OK?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah, so the
TPUs took the top three
spots in the overall
time metric with pods.
And then also the top two
spots, I believe, in the cost
using public cloud
computing resources.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
Well, what do you enjoy most
about working with these chips
and working with the
parallel processing?
JEFF DEAN: I actually
have been excited
about parallel processing
for quite some time,
ever since I took a course
my senior year at University
of Minnesota on
parallel processing.
And at the time, I was
really excited about that,
because I felt like more
computation was the answer
to solving a lot more problems.
And this was kind of during
the first wave of excitement
about neural nets that
happened in the late '80s
and early '90s, when new
algorithms were developed
and when it was first
surfacing as a potentially
interesting way to tackle
some difficult problems.
And at that time,
basically neural nets
could get interesting results
on very toy-sized problems,
but not sort of scale to
really interesting problems.
And so there was a wave
of excitement about this.
But then in this
wave of excitement,
I kind of felt like
more computation
was going to be
helpful for letting
us tackle bigger problems.
And so I did an undergrad thesis
working with the professor who
taught the parallel and
distributed computing class
I took, sort of did
an independent thesis
on parallel training
of neural nets.
And so I felt like if we
could take the 64 processor
machine we had in the
department and, you know,
apply parallel methods to
it, we could get, you know,
a factor of 60 more compute
applied to these things,
and then we could scale up
and tackle bigger problems.
In retrospect, we needed a
million times more computation,
not 60.
And so if you essentially just
wait it out with Moore's Law--
at least until about 5 or 10
years ago, when Moore's Law
significantly slowed down.
But before that, you know, the
previous 25 years, 40 years,
even, we were getting these
consistent 2x performance
improvement every two years.
You just wait long
enough, and all
of a sudden, voila, a million
times as much compute.
And you're golden.
And that's sort of what started
to happen in 2008, 2009.
It was we suddenly had
enough compute, initially
using GPU cards, which
were designed for gaming,
but obviously have turned out
to be quite useful for training
deep learning models, because
a lot of the acceleration you
want to do for
graphics processing
turns out to be amenable to
training deep learning models.
And so that was when people
in the academic community
started to really see
that we were starting
to get interesting results
on real problems using
neural nets.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
JEFF DEAN: So there
was kind of excitement
started to build back up.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
was one of the hardest
parts in your career?
It wasn't like AI
was well-accepted
for many, many years when you
were studying between then
and 2006 really, right?
So what was some of
the hardest moments
in terms of pursuing
this interest,
pursuing this research?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
I actually kind of come at this
as a general computer systems
person.
So I like to view
the kind of lens
I bring to problems is,
there's an interesting problem.
Let's figure out how we
can build a computer system
to tackle that problem,
often involving, you know,
either kind of good abstractions
for expressing computations
we want to perform or using
large amounts of computation
and figure out how to
parallelize or distribute
computation across
lots of machines
so that we can sort of
scale up the competition.
So, although I was doing
work as an undergrad
on this parallel
training of neural nets
I was coming at it from
the perspective of, how can
we built a computer
system to do this?
And then I sort of
started to get back
interested in machine
learning in 2011
when I happened to
bump into Andrew Ng
a microkitchen at Google--
MELANIE WARRICK: It
was going to say,
the story goes you were
in a microkitchen, right?
JEFF DEAN: Yes, yes.
So, I knew him a little
bit, and so I said,
oh, what are you doing here?
He's like, oh, I'm spending
a day a week at Google X,
and I haven't quite figured
out what I'm doing here yet,
but, you know, my
students at Stanford
are starting to see
what kinds of problems
can be solved with
neural nets, and they're
getting pretty good results.
I'm like, oh, really?
That's pretty cool.
I did a bit of work on
neural nets as an undergrad.
I said, they're
really working now?
And he's like, yeah.
So I said, we should train
really big neural nets.
And so that was
sort of the genesis
of how we decided to form the
Google Brain Project along
with Greg Corrado.
And we basically, at that
time, didn't have accelerators
or data centers.
But we said, we have
a lot of computers.
Let's figure out how to make
a computer system that can
train really big neural nets--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Let's leverage this.
JEFF DEAN: --using CPUs.
MARK MANDEL: And so is that
the moment where you like,
this is going to be
a really big thing.
Do you think it then?
JEFF DEAN: I did
feel like, you know,
once we kind of did a little bit
more work, maybe another month
of dabbling, then
it seemed like, hey,
we can actually tackle problems
using neural nets that people
have felt like they're the right
abstraction for a long time
but maybe they would suddenly
start to work in real problems
if we could apply
lots of computation.
And so that's really been
what a lot of my focus
has been on in the last
six or seven years,
is how can we bring lots of
computation to the problems
that you want to tackle
with machine learning,
and in particular deep learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: So, we're
recording this the day
after the Neural Information
Processing Systems Conference--
JEFF DEAN: NIPS.
MELANIE WARRICK: --sold out.
JEFF DEAN: Yes, yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: In 11
minutes and so many seconds.
JEFF DEAN: 48, I think.
MELANIE WARRICK: 48 seconds.
JEFF DEAN: 11 minutes
and 48 seconds.
Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
using this as an example.
There's a lot of excitement,
clearly, in this field.
How do you feel about
all this excitement?
JEFF DEAN: You know, there
is a fair amount of hype.
But on the other hand,
the hype, some of it
is actually justified,
because we're now actually
able to build systems that
can solve problems we couldn't
solve five or 10 years ago.
I mentioned computer vision.
Speech recognition has
advanced tremendously.
Translation has advanced.
Many applications of
these sorts of things
have shown real improvements
or new capabilities
in what computers can do.
So I think that's part of why
people are excited and many,
many people want
to enter the field.
So you see enrollment in
machine learning classes
at undergraduate
and graduate levels
just going through the roof.
You see more and more people
attending the major machine
learning conferences.
You see the number
of research papers
on archive actually growing
at a faster exponential rate
than Moore's Law over the
last seven or eight years.
It's quite remarkable.
And, you know, I think
it's important to temper
people's expectations
who think we're
going to have super-intelligent
things that can solve problems,
general problems that
humans can't solve,
in the next six months.
That's kind of the
one level of hype
that's clearly not justified.
But it's also
important to recognize
that computers can now see
that's a pretty big deal.
And that has major
implications across a bunch
of different areas.
You know, Google
here in Alphabet
are working on autonomous cars.
Clearly computer
vision and perception
is an important component of
making safe autonomous cars.
Robotics, machine learning
for medical imaging,
machine learning for other
medical applications,
health care
applications, these are
going to transform major
problems in the world.
And that's good.
That's why there's hype.
It's important to tamp
down excessive hype,
but not to say that there
shouldn't be any hype,
because I think we are
making significant advances
in what computers can do.
MELANIE WARRICK: Any
application in particular
that you've seen that you feel
don't get a lot of attention
but are pretty impactful?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
I mean, I think there's a
realization that I've come to
from looking at a few
different problems researchers
in our group have tackled and
other work that's going on,
where in many
scientific problems,
there are for example,
traditional high-performance
computing-based simulations
of some property,
some scientific thing.
Maybe you're simulating
chemical interactions
at a very fine grained level.
How do the electrons flow
around and what properties
does that have?
Or maybe you're simulating
earthquake faults
and you have a
very detailed sort
of physics-based model of how
slippage in earthquake faults
happens.
And often these
computational models
are very, very expensive
computationally.
So, you know, you
run one chemical
through your
simulator and an hour
later, you get information
about the quantum
properties of this chemical or
what binds to what or things
like that.
And you can actually use
that simulator as a teacher.
And so if you have a really
expensive scientific simulator,
often you can train a neural net
to do what that simulator does.
Completely end-to-end,
you take the inputs
you would have fed
to the simulator
and you get the outputs, and
you run a bunch of examples
through the simulator.
Now you have a training
set for a neural net.
And in a few different
domains, we've
actually seen people do this.
And in, for example, the quantum
chemistry domain, George Dahl
and others in our research
group worked with some chemists
at different universities
and took the simulator
they were using, trained
a neural net to do it,
and now they can't
distinguish the accuracy
versus the original sort
of HPC-style simulator.
But the tool is
300,000 times faster.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
JEFF DEAN: And any
time you take your tool
and you make it
300,000 times faster,
that just transforms how
you would do science, right?
You can imagine, oh, I'm
going to go make coffee.
Let me screen 100 million
molecules and then
when I come back, I'll
look at the 10,000
that are most interesting.
And that same thing happened
with Brendan Meade, who
was a visiting Harvard
faculty member who
visited our group in
Cambridge for a year
and did a bunch of work on
earthquake fault simulation.
He relayed that
in work he'd just
done before he came
to visit us, that he'd
replaced the earthquake fault
simulation inner loop with kind
of the world's
lamest neural net.
It was, you know, four
layers of 10 neurons each.
And all of a sudden, the thing
was between 10,000 and 100,000
times faster.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
JEFF DEAN: And he couldn't tell
the difference in accuracy.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
JEFF DEAN: So, I think that's
a good lens to look at,
you know, are you doing
scientific computing
or simulation of some sort?
Can you then train a neural net
to do an approximation of that
that is quite likely to
be accurate if you give it
enough training data?
MARK MANDEL: And now
I'm just thinking of--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Giving you ideas.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I
work with my games.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know, games.
MARK MANDEL: And
so, now I'm like,
if you can get that
kind of performance
for that level of
simulation, you
can do some really
interesting things.
JEFF DEAN: Right, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I think I
saw you speak about this, too,
that you're using neural
nets as well to help
with improving the actual
performance of the systems
themselves.
JEFF DEAN: There's a big
opportunity in general computer
systems.
So if you think about what's at
the heart of operating systems
or compilers or storage systems
or other computer systems,
they're generally
laden with kind
of hand-written heuristics.
You know, which process
should the operating system
schedule next, out of the ready
processes that are available?
Or for a compiler,
should it, you know,
emit code with this loop net
ordering or this loop ordering?
Or which, you know,
variable should it
spill the memory when it can't
fit them all in registers?
And in many cases, I
believe these are actually
learning problems.
And so the heuristics that
people tend to handwrite
have to work well
in the general case.
And they can't really be
developed in such a way
that they completely adapt to
how the system is being used.
So to give you an example, in
our Bigtable storage system,
you know, there's essentially
a key value store.
And client requests come
in to Bigtable servers,
and they can request
that certain data be
read from different tables.
And when that happens,
the Bigtable server
decides to put it in
a named memory cache,
so if that data is needed
again, then, you know,
you have it in the cache.
You don't have to go
to disc and fetch it.
And if you look,
lots of information
is available at the time you
make the decision to read
the data from disc.
We know, for example,
the internal user group
of the job that's
running the process that
requested the data.
We know maybe the job
name that requested this.
And you would never
write a heuristic--
so a lot of the processing is
from sequential MapReduce style
processing jobs that are going
to read the data once, never
use it again, until
an hour later when
a similar MapReduce starts up.
But you don't really want
to insert that in the cache,
because you're not going to get
any reuse sort of immediately.
But you would never
write a heuristic
in the middle of
your Bigtable server
that says, if job name
starts with MapReduce dash,
then don't insert in the cache.
But if you look at what a
learning heuristic could do,
it would pretty quickly
learn the pattern
that these jobs that seem
to start with MapReduce dash
never seem to reuse the
data I insert in the cache,
so I'm just not
going to insert it.
And I think there's huge
potential for the thousands
and thousands and thousands of
heuristics in computer systems
to really mostly be learned and
adapt to how they're actually
being used.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
wonderful and exciting, too,
to think about the ways that
this could be improved upon.
I feel like there's so many
things I want to ask you,
and we definitely are going
to be limited on time.
So I want to make
sure I make some space
and time for the
fact that you're
going to be in South Africa
when we release this.
And specifically, you're there
to speak at the Deep Learning
Indaba that's taking place
outside of Cape Town.
So can you tell us a
little bit about how you're
involved in this, the
conference itself,
and what you're going
to be speaking about?
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
So I'm going to give a talk on
solving challenging problems
in the world of deep
learning, or something.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
JEFF DEAN: And actually,
the way it's framed
is around the National
Academy of Engineering put out
in 2008 a list of important
problems for the engineering
community writ large to
work on in the 21st century.
And it's a list of
14 different areas,
things like improve
medical informatics,
develop better drugs,
improve solar energy output.
And if you look at
them, I actually
think machine learning
will be useful for tackling
smaller or larger pieces of
all of those different things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
JEFF DEAN: And so
the talk is framed
a bit as like, hey, here's some
interesting work that we've
done that is part of
the way toward solving
some of these grand
challenge kind of areas.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
JEFF DEAN: And so that Deep
Learning Indaba, I think,
is a really exciting event.
It's a gathering of--
I think it's about
400 or 500 people
from around mostly
the African continent
from different countries.
And really there's a burgeoning
and an exciting community
in Africa that is excited
about using machine
learning and doing
machine learning research,
using machine learning to tackle
problems in countries in Africa
and around the world.
And I think this
is really exciting,
to see this swelling of a
research community in Africa,
as well as the
rest of the world.
So I'm excited to go
take part in that.
I actually lived in Uganda
and Somalia as a kid.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
JEFF DEAN: So I just
cared deeply about--
MELANIE WARRICK: It
matters a lot to you,
to be able to participate and
to see and grow this group.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know, too, that Brain
has expanded into Ghana.
And there's an
outfit that's being
led by Moustapha Cisse,
who we, at some point,
hopefully, will get to
come on the podcast as
well, because I've met
him and he's wonderful.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds great.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
JEFF DEAN: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: He's great.
And I know they're off the
ground and running as we speak.
Are there, you
know, other groups
that you're looking to
grow, or are other offices
that you're looking to spin up
that you can even speak about?
Or is that something we
can't talk about right now?
JEFF DEAN: We're very excited
about the Ghana office.
We're in the final throes of
renovating the office space,
and we've hired a bunch
of people for the office
that I think is going
to be a great addition
to our global
research organization.
They're going to do fantastic
work in both basic machine
learning research,
looking at some sort
of interesting applied problems
that are particular to Ghana
and the rest of Africa.
And I think it's
going to be great.
I love Moustapha.
He's a wonderful
leader, and it's great
that we have him in the office.
MELANIE WARRICK: He's a
wonderful person out there.
The other thing I
wanted to ask you,
or a couple of other things.
So looking forward to Deep
Learning Indaba, anybody who's
out there who has
interest, there'll
be resources we'll
provide on the show notes.
The last couple things we
want to make sure we touch on
before we let you go.
Love to know what is one of
the best pieces of advice
that you've received
in your career.
JEFF DEAN: I don't know if it's
a specific piece of advice that
I've received, but an
observation I've made
throughout my career is
that really good way to do
interesting things is to partner
with people who know things
that you don't.
And I often find that working
on projects with three
or four people
where you each have
kind of different
kinds of expertise
and collectively you
kind of come together
to tackle some interesting
problem that none of you
could solve individually,
but collectively you can,
because you have the full
totality of techniques
or can develop them.
And the reason that's
really important
is it's a good way to
continuously learn new things,
even after you
get out of school.
You know, I think when you're
in undergraduate or graduate
school or whatever, you're
obviously learning things.
But it's important
to kind of continue
to learn things and
pick up new ideas
and sort of
stimulate your brain.
And this is a really
good way to do that.
And then you kind of go
off of that project and go
onto a different project, and
some of the other people's
expertise has kind of rubbed
off as a sheen on you.
And you can now at
least look at problems
through the lens of
the kinds of expertise
they have and say, oh, yeah,
that looks a lot like this.
I know the questions to
ask or the right approach
to take in tackling
this, even if that's not
your sort of formal background.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Definitely.
You mentioned about Moore's
Law and the amount of research
that's coming out and
papers in particular.
How do you keep up
on the resources
and the research and all that?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
I mean, again, I think
this is something
where surrounding yourself
with people who know things
that you don't is a really
good way, because if you have
a good network of people
that you interact with,
they can partly be
your eyes and ears
and look out for interesting
things in their sort of area
of focus and say, oh, yeah,
that's kind of interesting.
Someone told me
about this today.
And you can kind
of start to connect
the dots between different
areas and see the potential
for a technique
developed over here,
how it might be used over here,
or how it might combine well
with some other technique and
really build on each other.
So I think it's very hard
to keep up with everything.
So you need to sort
of collectively
find some things you really
do follow yourself, and then
get a cursory level of
information about other things.
One thing I've observed
is that a lot of people
really, really deeply
read a research paper.
And I think that's
important sometimes,
but it's kind of the wrong
approach for general learning.
I think you'd be
much better served
to take the time to read
100 abstracts of 100
different papers and
sort of understand
the highest-level concept
that they each have.
Because you can always go
read that thing in more detail
if you need to find
out more about it.
But being able to have those
100 pieces of information of
like, oh, yeah,
that's a technique.
That's a thing.
We can kind of do
something like that.
That's how you really
start to connect the dots
and make connections
across fields
or across different problems.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Any
specific public research
you've heard of very
recently that specifically
comes to your mind, that you're
like, this is exciting to me?
Or--
JEFF DEAN: Well, I
think the general idea
of having computers
that can automatically
do experiments, and then
measure the results of those,
and then sort of
continuously absorb
the results of a first
set of experiments,
and then generate
new experiments.
So all of the neural
architectures search work
or the AutoML work that
our group has been doing,
a lot of the
reinforcement learning
based work that is showing
promise in solving games
like Go or OpenAI work on Dota.
I think all these
things kind of point
at that general direction
of having computers
that can automatically explore
different approaches to solving
problems is going
to be important.
Because a computer can
run 50,000 experiments
whereas a human runs 50,
looks at the results,
and then figures out, what
are the next 50 to run?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
And then the other
question I want
to ask you, out of all the
interviews you've ever done,
what question do you wish
people would ask you?
JEFF DEAN: I will tell
you one interesting thing
that some people don't know.
So I actually moved
around a lot as a kid.
I went to 11
schools in 12 years.
And I think that's--
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a lot of schools.
JEFF DEAN: That is a
lot of schools, yes.
The, like, oh, new
year, new school.
MELANIE WARRICK: You learned
how to make a lot of friends,
I'm sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
I mean, I think it was
pretty helpful for me,
because it let me live in
lots of different places, lots
of different kinds of
environments, everywhere
from Hawaii, Boston, Uganda,
Boston, Arkansas, Hawaii,
Minnesota, Somalia,
Atlanta, Geneva, Seattle,
and the Bay Area.
And--
MELANIE WARRICK: You must
not be open minded at all.
JEFF DEAN: I think it
does help, because you
can find really great aspects
of any of those places.
And I think that's a
good perspective to have.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Before we wrap up,
any resources you
want to recommend to
our listeners for people
want to get into deep learning,
TPUs, Google Brain, just ML
research?
JEFF DEAN: You know, I'm
asked this question a lot,
and a lot of it depends on
the kind of level of expertise
someone already has.
So I think I don't
have a single answer,
but I recommend-- you know,
there's lots of good blogs
out there.
Chris Olah's blog and
the distill.pub journal
that he started with
Shan Carter are really
good expositions for people with
a certain level of expertise.
I think there's things like the
Machine Learning Crash Course
that Google put out.
There's lots of courses
on Udacity and Coursera
for different
levels of expertise.
The deep learning textbook that
Ian Goodfellow, Yoshua Bengio,
and Aaron Courville put
out is a very good one.
There's lots of
material targeted
at sort of people with
less advanced math
skills for high school students
and middle school students,
even.
So there's just a wealth
of information out there,
and it's really great that
the community is producing
so much introductory material
and more advanced material
for everyone.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, we did cover the
fact that you're speaking
at Deep Learning Indaba.
Anything else that you wanted
to mention before we let you go?
JEFF DEAN: No, I'm
just really excited.
Thanks for having me, and
thanks for the conversation.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you so much for coming on.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thanks so much.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Appreciate it much.
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you again, Jeff.
It was really great to just
get into all the things.
And one of the many things that
I really appreciated from that
was hearing that he still codes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: He has--
he's like, this is my day.
MARK MANDEL: Monday I code.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
that is when I will code.
So it's hard to do
that as you become
more senior, to make that
type of space in your life.
So anyways, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: So we have our
wonderful friend here, Gabe.
GABE WEISS: Whee.
MARK MANDEL: Hey.
So Gabe, we have a
wonderful question for you,
because we know you
do stuff in IoT Core.
GABE WEISS: I'm ready.
MARK MANDEL: If I have
an IoT Core thing,
how do I get my
data from IoT Core
to display in real time
on a web front-end?
I believe you've done
something like this.
GABE WEISS: I have, recently.
So anyone that's
worked in IoT knows
there's a bajillion
different ways to do this.
There's different
classes of devices.
There different protocols.
There's different everything.
So there's-- how many grains
of sand on a beach are there?
That's how many
ways are to do this.
The way that we did it as
kind of our golden path
at Cloud Next in 2018, we
built an entire end-to-end app
on stage.
There are five of us.
So we went from devices.
We used a Raspberry
Pi with some sensors
that we did
measuring heart rate.
And that will
communicate with MQTT,
is the protocol that we used
that IoT Core understands
how to receive.
So you can send your telemetry
data from your devices
to IoT Core.
From IoT Core, it gets bridged.
All of your telemetry
data becomes
events in Cloud Pub/Sub, which
is our event stream manager.
From Cloud Pub/Sub, you can
trigger Cloud Functions,
which we did to pull the
telemetry data out of Pub/Sub
and put it into our
data warehouse, which
was Cloud Firestore.
We picked Firestore because
it's a NoSQL database,
it's super low latency,
and it has a special sauce,
which is it has a push mechanism
so that front end apps can
register for a callback when any
data changes in the database.
So for real time
applications, this is huge.
So our front end
was an Angular app
that we wrote that
subscribed to this callback
from Firestore that pulls
it in and draws our heart
rates on a graph.
So end-to-end, it was device
up to IoT Core, which gets
bridged int the Cloud Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub had a Cloud
Function that pulls from it,
shoves it into Cloud Firestore.
Firestore triggered with its
callback into an Angular app.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
GABE WEISS: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
GABE WEISS: That
was pretty cool.
It all worked, too.
MARK MANDEL: Say that
three times quickly.
GABE WEISS: I know, I can't.
I did it once.
That was good enough, right?
MARK MANDEL: That works.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That was really good.
MARK MANDEL: If people--
is a public sample or anything
that people can actually
go and have a look at?
GABE WEISS: Yeah.
So the easiest way
to find it is going
to be if on YouTube you do
a search for "Building IoT
Applications on Google Cloud."
It's the only one on there.
You'll find our video
from the conference.
And in the links
in the description
is a link to the GitHub
with all of our code.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
Well, thanks, Gabe.
We appreciate you
coming on and helping
us do the question of the week.
GABE WEISS: Thanks
for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark.
Where are you going to be?
MARK MANDEL: What am I doing?
What's happening?
MELANIE WARRICK: What you doing?
What you know?
MARK MANDEL: So, when this
comes out, I will be in Tokyo.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, you will.
MARK MANDEL: I'm getting
ready for Tokyo Next.
So, pretty excited about that.
I'm talking there about
Agones, talking to some gaming
people and stuff.
So if you're in
town, come say hi.
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: And I
will be in Stellenbosch.
I think I've probably said
that a lot at this point.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: But I will be
there doing some interviews.
And then you and I will
both be in Strange Loop
at the end of the month.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, which
is going to be really good.
Gabe, you going anywhere
special in the next month or so?
GABE WEISS: I am.
I'm doing a European trip.
I'm doing London,
Paris, Barcelona
for a series of conferences.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh,
that sounds difficult.
GABE WEISS: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Which
conferences are you going to?
GABE WEISS: So London
is Cloud Next--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
GABE WEISS: --which is
our kind of next iteration
of our series.
And then Paris is
visiting teammates,
because I have a weird kind of
five days I don't want to fly
back and forth to Europe.
And Barcelona is the big IoT
conference, IoT Solutions World
Congress, which is kind of the
big European IoT conference.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
GABE WEISS: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
have a good trip.
GABE WEISS: Thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark, I think
that's it for us this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so Melanie and Gabe,
thanks for joining us for yet
another week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
GABE WEISS: Thanks.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]